Mr Beast recently on a podcast the
flagrant podcast revealed that he turned
down a one billion dollar offer for his
YouTube channel and he said I'm clearly
not looking to sell at this point he
said maybe if it was a 10 or 20 billion
I would even consider it for now
um that would make me more comfortable
handing over the keys to my kingdom But
ultimately I think it could be worth way
more I think people on the outside of
what's happening in the YouTube world in
the content world are absolutely shocked
by that but from your perspective do you
think that he made a bad call or do you
think that he's exactly right he's way
undervaluing uh What It Is Well I mean a
couple things one your business is worth
whatever the market is willing to pay
you we don't have the details of what
was offered to him but let's do some
basic math okay so I just pulled up his
channel his most viewed video is 293
million views it's a 25 minute video
that's the 456 thousand dollar squid
game that he did which was all over the
place in one note about that as well is
he's also doing multiple different
channels absolutely dubbed so his most
viewed video squid game is actually
higher in another language yeah and I'm
aware of that so but let's do this
together so Super Bowl commercial you do
30 seconds what do you paying 5.2
million dollars give or take right
and Super Bowl gets roughly 100 million
views okay so if we take 300 million
people watching the Super Bowl which is
the number here not including all the
other stuff which means a 60-second clip
in this 25 minute video is what
16 million dollars okay so if he's able
to get a billion views because it's in
other languages then that means that's
now a 50 million dollar one video on
that number then you take that I don't
know how many videos he's got if we go
over here and we see how many videos is
uploaded he's got total 17 billion views
I'll just do the number on 17 billion
views we can do together right now on
just one channel okay let's do this
together 17 billion views divided by 100
million because that's what Super Bowl
claims so that's 170 times
5 million bucks okay
minimum that that thing is worth 850
million dollars so one channel so I've
never even been asked this question nor
have I done the math his one channel
alone has generated a minimum of 850
million dollars and I'm calculating only
one commercial so assume on each video
he can do Five Sixty Second commercials
if we go to five on that that's 4.2
billion dollars that he has in his in
his channel so I uh uh and then add it
to all the other channels that he has I
think he's right 10 to 20 billion
dollars the right number and YouTube
revenue and also the commercial spots
and then also and I I'm not sure if in
the deal he's got Beast Burger now
because I think it might have been for
his Empire he's got a restaurant oh my
God the entire Empire they offered a
billion I'm not sure but that's that's
what he was he was saying this is I
haven't I I heard about it people ask me
but if it's for the whole thing and does
he come with it and how many years does
he come with it and how many minimum
Clips is he gonna do per month how many
videos is it gonna do if if all of that
comes together I think he's right it's a
10 billion dollar no I wouldn't be
selling you less than 10 billion if you
enjoyed this content and want to take
your YouTube channel to the next level
just click or tap the link on the screen
or go to
tube1kchallenge.com to join our next
live YouTube challenge you'll learn our
best tips and strategies that are
working here at think media and I think
you'll love it